we look at this have using it a lot
disloyal and I said you can't use it
with this at least not the way it looks
at the moments sometimes in mathematics
you have to make things worse before
they get better they don't clean their
desk before out of your desk looks like
mine my desk is terrible it's a complete
disaster so when I decide I can't
understand my whole day clean this I
take everything off it eventually ends
up all on the floor right and then after
it's on the floor it looks terrible I
can actually organize it and get it in
its right spot the safety is going to
happen here click can you tell us what
was your first line coming out of this
that's great
yep like on this place or
- for me
okay let's pause for a bit before we
move on from this line I will point out
two things number one I wrap those edges
with dashes through them the reason why
as you might be able to look at the
board
my dad might choose really sabab and
yours alter the two especially when
you're in Ohio you're writing think
there's a good chance that a large
proportion of the people this room well
what they're doing mathematics attention
to which we're going to learn if they
did it when you did public or copy
numbers so that's why I do this just a
habit
secondly what might that technique does
are you done two things
he is rewritten this we have a reason to
do this we have a precedent for doing
this this lesson why is this a useful
thing have a look at the moment we've
done this already today why did we do
this the first time we did it over here
why do we do it any suggestions depends
of the power would okay so when you've
written the powers in a way that can be
canceled like this can collapse back
into this quite easily right the reason
we do that is again a keeps Amos it
reveals the structure of what this
object is then to the four we call this
a quarter by the way quarter because
it's powerful then to the four is a
square just doesn't look like it is not
dressed up in the square okay
but when you write the power's out just
like with these guys you can see oh this
is a square is a square hiding
underneath here and if it's a square you
could use all these other results that
you know that's not the only thing that
they could know though what else did he
do I look at the row yeah he added
something and then he subtracted the
same thing because I don't know is we
just like it I why is this useful
I think the injury from birth better be
good so adding and subtracting something
the first thing we want to notice is
this is fine you can totally do this
right this is a trick that we sort of
employ this is the trick we employ every
time we work with fractions and because
they search ësocial won't talk to each
other in this form we multiply and then
we divide right so that you can get a
common to not a we're familiar with this
we're just resting
expression up doing something and
undoing it which is totally fine so that
we can get something at the end it's
more useful okay
Nelligan this object here maybe it
doesn't stand out so obviously to fury
or gear because you have a big deal it
is quite long but if you can or to
recognize it see these three terms
what are they these three terms here are
done we've had to help to identify
because he's written this is it to air
this is a perfect square this is perfect
square it's something squared what is
for something good then squared plus two
so this guy up here is written in the
form something squared something else
squared and nestled in the middle you
have plus 2 a B now maybe you're not
used to recognizing that kind of thing
and therefore that kind of thing as a
perfect square but you get better with
AD with practice I like to think of it
like this showing people this before if
this is a and this is B this is a and
this is B so this is a square the
trouble can you write a plus B times a
plus B how I look at the rectangle
you're going to get the area of this one
but at the area of this one and then you
know these two big guys this one over
here is a times B so it's this is the
same this is a compact angle it's just
on its side it's also a B and there's
where your tribe it comes from ok so now
that we've written it we have
successfully factorize them then you
have this guy off on the end I'm going
to rewrite it slightly differently to
make more obvious on where next step is
for dead square is also that's where
what's in the square of 2
- yeah it's Tuesday or swear do you
notice that the two decks squared and
then there's egg gets wet okay and the
room is there
we're always there what can I use now
yeah that's great that's graceful secure
plasticity we couldn't use difference of
squares before but after they helped us
out you can see differences created
they're hiding underneath this square
take away this query ok now let me
remind you this is why simplifying is
not always the best word to use is this
thing simpler than what we started with
at least in terms of what the expression
looks like no it is not to block this is
much nicer and quicker to write however
this is more revealing this shows us the
structure and so yes I'm just looking
this is as far as I would go
you can lastly factorize if you wanted
to but in your one there actually stood
for you can work out more things about
this before plus four by knowing that
you could write it in this thing okay